it is my pleasure to announce that the
13th World chess champion Gary Kasparov
is here and ready to join us on the show
Welcome Gary thank you thank you so am I
too late so is the round
over you're almost too late Gary but
you're one of the great attacking
players Gary and we saw this move D5 and
I'm disappointed Gary that leavon did
not capture Bishop takes
again remember I'm watching you know I'm
watching on internet and I'm just behind
so that's why you have to tell me what
happened
after saw I saw Bishop F4 what happened
Bishop F4 Bishop F4 after the move
Bishop F4 came yeah C5 C5 Queen D2 D5
yes correct C5 Bishop takes H6 yes
please Gary break this down for us we
were just looking at Bishop takes H6 G
takes H6 t
Queen takes H6 Knight Knight H7 H7 yes
well we were looking at Rook E6 but
Knight
H7 KN I saw Knight H7 Knight H5 F6 I
thought ah Knight H7 Knight so this
these these were the first moves that
ran through your mind okay that's yeah I
just wanted to to to have my queen you
know just
defending the king
so right Queen no but it's yeah but yeah
it's
not Knight F5 followed by Rook 81 and we
continue slowly but it feels Knight F5
yes Knight F5 F6 Rook 81 yes M yes F6
Rook a D1
yes yeah I should probably go Queen F
Queen F7 yes we
take take by by by probably Pawn Yeah
Queen G6
Rook takes C5 though que yes yes yes yes
sorry sorry sorry that's que Rook Rook
D5 no no no yeah that's the yeah
that's yeah maybe still yes very yeah
would have been a lot more exciting that
what than than what we're about to
witness I was but after Rook E6 you play
also Knight F5 yes of course
yeah Rook E6 yes take on H6 Rook E6
Knight F5 and then Queen G5 Check Yes
Knight F5 well this this position we
actually were very interested in I it
just felt like the engines are saying
it's even Gary but but it's but even but
it's exciting exactly yeah and maybe you
like to be white in such positions you
you you feel is it practical for one to
roll the D you know as a professional
player you also know that it's so easy
to sacrifice you know other other other
people's pieces
as a professional chess commentator it's
my great honor and
Glory you finished the sentence yeah of
course we we have to we have to
sacrifice of course we do I I I think
white has excellent position so it's
it's very entertaining and I would say
very little risk yeah it's it's easy to
play with white it's easy to even if
position is even by m from machines
perspective so for
humans yeah and also what what was the
alternative I mean just to two the game
continuation unfortunately the
alternative is the game continuation
Gary and the game continuation is not
attractive at all what happened in the
game is all the pieces got traded off uh
uh leavon instead of sacrificing he took
on E5 Rook takes E5 Rook D1 and
unfortunately Gary we've seen this
throughout the tournament for leavon
he's not inspired his play is not
inspired him to
play and we will sometimes you know is
this it's it's you um you have players
that are just getting tired of the
tournament and they want us to finish it
yes so it's the it's I I I I remember
that this this this V announced comments
when this is the at the end of our match
in in in in New York yes 995 so because
I just you know I want to make quick
drawing in game was white and and he was
asked so why why didn't you try okay he
was he was losing minus three so it was
clearly you know that the match was over
and and V said you know put put put you
in my shoes so it's this how can you
play you know just you know was I think
he said he just something like nail
biting just he clearly didn't want to
play anymore so get out of here yeah
exactly so uh yeah uh so I think it's
Leon probably had no no
energy just to to go for it I but still
I would think it's if the tournament
goes poorly why not to take on A6 have
fun exactly exactly and also we will be
happy we will be rooting
where uh Gary I I what else happened
there because I saw I saw I saw yeah
it's okay it's a draw just take it away
take it away uh for me Gary I wanted to
ask you a question uh I refer to the
game between nepo and Niche for a moment
if you don't mind cuz what happened in
this game was actually extraordinary
seriously it's not a joke nepo played 20
moves and had 96 Minutes it just like
blitzing blitzing blitzing Anish was
taking his time taking his time the gap
between them became an hour and I began
reflecting on the fact that I once
played against vishi and nand where the
difference in our clocks was even closer
to to two hours what has been the worst
example for you where your opponent just
Blitz throughout the whole
game um
um I'm not so sure not so sure
not you got stopped because you need you
need there are very few players who
could actually who could Blitz their way
through V was one of them this game has
just just to interrupt you sorry Gary
but we do have a handshake between
leavon and the laner our congratulations
to the wild carder finishing with plus
two yes please sorry uh do continue Gary
uh
um you know it's this it's not about the
game but it's just it's the uh but
uh you mentioned V yes so
uh I think it was our
first classical chess game we played in
um
linaris in uh
91 yeah yeah L 1991 so and uh it was
petro and uh um I I was very happy
because it was a really tight tournament
so I started po I lost to even but then
I just you know I was gradually catching
up and with um three rounds to go I
think three round yes three rounds to go
so I think were we were EV so and I had
I had to play vishi luo and and yup and
two whites so and I was very optimistic
so I think three rounds to go yes yeah
um and uh I we had um was wishing we had
petro and I followed now analysis
because we prepared this line for kpov
in 1990 so uh and we found some new
ideas I remember work with Sergey delat
this is the it's the it's a third move
d4 so so it's it's a very long line and
um vishy played you know by you know
just all the theoretical moves and then
just you know we the position and I was
already sitting you know okay now this
is this analysis it's everything you
should work in my favor and vishy just
for couple spent couple of minutes very
and he played I remember Rook takes D2
so this is It's returning the exchange
so this and and I just you know it play
so quickly again it doesn't solve all
the problems but I was really annoyed by
him playing so quickly and I just you
know I made a mistake and he escaped and
was a draw and and it's you know that's
that's what I ended up actually I beat
luo but then I just I uh Drew was L and
even took won the tournament first
tournament I I have not won in since
since 1981 so um and and that's you know
it was only one move but still you know
he's you know the the confidence that he
made a move I remember Rook takes D2 I
just you know yes caught me by not
surprised but again was annoying very
annoying I want to turn your attention
to the game of Fabiano and Richard
report stop but it's it's yeah he played
very quickly but the position I saw will
look very good for white which one the
um the NEPA position ah the NEPA
position he spent he spent a little time
but you know it looked like his position
was I mean was considering the time you
spent you know was too good right yeah
um jump in uh what's just happened
things are actually getting quite
interesting there because uh Anish is
now because of the pressure on the clock
Yan is still above an hour and is is
down to 3 minutes only uh but he's only
need needs to make two more moves and he
played a good move here Rook B3 which I
think requires a lot of calculation
because you need to worry about Knight
E5 after knight5 your pieces are still
are still hanging there's ideas of
Knight takes G4 and Rook H1 check6 F6
yes I think both Knight C8 and Knight G6
are okay F6 might still no hang on F6
Knight takes G4 sorry sorry yeah so he
will have to choose between Knight C8
and Knight G6 both of which are okay
Knight C8 very specifically because
after Rook F7 the Knight Returns to the
game with great effect attacks The Rook
on F7 attacks the B on e4 but if this
were move 35 this would have been very
very exciting and also very promising
for Yan I think but with only two moves
to make it feels like Kish will probably
uh be okay but yeah Yan managed to
generate a lot of excitement from a
position which we thought was quite dry
so yeah I think he he's played a
surprisingly interesting game today from
uh what looked like uh a very level
situation yeah and what about the game
between Fabby and Richard because this
game has much more energy uh Jo I mean
look uh more pieces on the board also if
AB wins and he will be seeing Phil cop
winner out as well uh night
just take us H how would you break down
the position between Fabby and Richard
exactly at this point we just saw the
move Knight F3 to G5 I'm not sure about
Richie's move Bishop f8 by the way
but how do you how do you like them
apples
Gary why this why this slightly better
clearly and no doubt about it okay so U
so I I guess that he wants to play
Knight E4 yes now yes I wonder I wonder
why you play Knight
G5 Knight G I don't know it's sort of
annoying okay maybe okay you don't
expect H6 Knight takes C6 I mean I'm
sure that would be nice you don't expect
you don't expect H6 so then why do you
play Knight G5 so what what is not your
knight doing on
G5 it's there H4
potentially my queen could come over to
F3 okay I don't say there's a rook lift
in the position but is this a is this
not okay let me make a bad move sorry uh
let me make a bad move take take let me
make some more bad moves Rook D3 Knight
here and now we stop because we've got
checkmates down the H file uh I I leave
the details to yourselves but uh night
H7 Rook H3 I sacrific my queen yeah but
Rook H3 H6 actually you have to make
sure it works uh Rook H aha that's a
Pity but there how about Knight H7
unfortunately there's a bishop H6
included somewhere we take on C2 we take
on C2 and after Knight F6 we actually go
into the corner not to G7 you do what we
going we go into the corner I no no
sorry I go Knight F6 check of course
King H King h8 unfortunately
yes yeah it's The Rook on A1 is hanging
otherwise you could have won the queen
but Rook on A1 is hanging and now Bishop
H6 years yeah and I I free the f8 square
to run yeah W actually variation ah I
have F6 I was getting very excited there
for uh the idea of going Rook takes H6
here King G7 Knight G4 and then Bishop
F6 but there will be F7 F6 there yeah
yeah6 yeah Knight G4 check I think king
of fa might actually be losing king of
fa Bishop F6
KING5 five and this I was so excited
about this oh but this unfortunately
does not quite happen because you both
spotted F6
check yeah F6 here probably solves all
of these it's an answer to the check
sorry does it though Bishop takes F6
hang on a second but but it's it's still
it's still a draw is I've got to
prepare it's a king F7 Rook H6 Rook A7
and you have to go King
G8 uh yeah king8 is still made yes 95
still made what's the difference I mean
before exists but yeah it's bad okay uh
so you have to go back and then we're
going to make hang on a second Rook G7
King h8 King ah King h8 no king h8 is no
no King f8 King f8 King f8 uh yeah you
have to go King f8 and I wanted to go
Knight
H6 uh I wanted to go like full
on you you both read the same uh
but this is still a draw of the king E8
unfortunately still a
draw uh so this is why I think Knight G5
is in Fabby he's got these ideas of a
rook lift a Rover Rook up and over
Knight G5 and he's trying to be annoying
psychological yes because because you
know uh uh uh Rober you know is just
he's very aggressive player and uh and
maybe now he he's seeing some some you
know hallucinations now it was night on
G5 was this yeah so by did you play A5
no no he played Knight G4 which is a
good reply I think Knight G4 uh Gary uh
sorry we've got uh people in studio
ready waiting to be interviewed tell us
when you're coming to town and you're
going to be joining us for the Gaya
correct tomorrow of course tomorrow
tomorrow yes yes tomorrow by lunchtime
yes so I just have one quick question
I'd just like to ask your opinion on so
uh who do you think will make it to the
candidates we've seen so many so much
speculation this is so yeah but it's I
think it's about mathematics now so I'm
not following the details because it's
about ratings it's and then a fe the
points I don't think I I I can tell you
that this you have to ask you know the
the book is not
me on that note thank you very much Gary
for joining
us tomorrow gay no second of December is
the gay exactly thank you uh Gary and
we're going to ch